hello everybody welcome to the sixth
video for image recognition and image
manipulation where we left off what
we're talking about how we were going to
combat different colors and all that and
what we're going to be doing is thresh
holding so to do that what we're going
to do is make a little function that
will convert the image to just pure
black and white so there will be no hue
or anything like that like there will be
no gray will just be black or white so
we're going to make a function to do
this so this probably the most confusing
part of this entire series up to this
point but I'll try to talk you guys
through it at each step of the way so
the first thing I want to do is let's
just go ahead and delete all of this for
now we'll come back to that in a little
bit so let's start making this threshold
function and a lot of times when I'm
building functions I like to put in a
short sleeper just because like in this
case we're going to print out a bunch of
arrays sometimes you might want to slow
it down so I'm just going to import time
as well so you can do that if you want
to follow along so now we're going to do
is define threshold as a function and
the parameter that will pass through is
image array so some will throw some sort
of array at this threshold function and
it's going to change the values of that
array to make the image pure black or
white so well each pixel in the image
black or white that's what we're going
to do next the next thing I want to do
is the way that we're going to do this
is we're going to just find out what the
average colors of the array are and then
we're going to well anyway we're going
to find out the average code of the
array and anything above that will be a
white anything below that will be a
black so to do that I'm going to make a
variable balanced array and it's going
to be empty and what that's going to do
is basically every value that go that
we're going to consider will go into
balanced array and then at the end we're
going to average balanced array so now
we'll come down and we're going to say
new array equals M
jerae and this is just going to be so we
can actually start to manipulate this
array otherwise numpy would get mad at
us so now we're going to do is for each
part in image array so so this is each
row right in that image right then we're
going to say for um for the parts in
each or so really what I could say and
actually yeah let's do that to make this
this is more obvious so for each row an
image marais image array and then we're
going to say for each pics for each
pixel in each row um let's go ahead and
print that out just so you can see
visually where we stand so print each
pix and then we'll just put a time sleep
for 5 seconds so let's run that and when
we do this um oh shoot we're going to
need a few more things this goes out of
this row quick let's come down to the
bottom here and we're going to just do
I'd like to do kind of a few images
actually
so let's code in a few few images here
so let's do I equals capital I image
open and then what do we want to open we
want to open images slash number slash
well the first one we'll just do 0.1
right PNG so that's a typical 0 the next
one we want to do herbal soup higher
equals MP dot array and in the
parameters I and then just copy and
paste this because we're going to do a
few more images here so I'm going to
make some space and paste paste base so
this one we're going to use a yellow
version for the one do yellow version 5
and then we'll do images slash cent Dex
PNG so that's going to bring up that
sense
image so now first let's actually plot
this all these up so we can see what
we're working with
so we'll come back down here now and
we're just going to say fig equals plot
figure you don't really need this but if
you ever wanted to edit that figure it's
there and then we're going to say ax 1
equals we got to do the same thing for
all the other axes and it's going to
plot dot subplot to grid and then in
there here you've got the size of this
grid so it's going to be 8 by 6 followed
by the starting point right the top left
starting point this is going to be at 0
0 and then you're going to say how many
rows is going to span we'll say for how
many columns is it going to span that's
going to be a 3 subsequently we're going
to just copy and paste this uh 2 3 4 and
rename this to 3 and 4 and then change
the starting points so this will be 0 0
the top one this will be 4 0 this will
start at 0 3 and this one will start at
4 3 so it'll be 2 on top 2 on the bottom
if you don't follow just kind of copy
what I've done and then you'll see it
visually in just a second
next we're going to do oh and you know
what else we need to do we need to edit
these so this will be eye to eye r 2i 3i
r 3i 4i are 4 and then down here we'll
do a X 1m show and we'll do I R and then
we'll do a X 2m show and this will be IR
to a X 3m show this will be IR 3 and a
export in show will be IR 4 and the last
thing we want to do is just do o'clock
show and actually bring this up so let's
go ahead and save that run it and you
should get a pop-up of this and
something went wrong I'll have to look
through it and see what we did wrong so
it shouldn't be all all like that let's
see
okay yeah what we do right so this is I
this needs to be i2 i3 and i-4 and save
that and run it again okay this time we
did it right so as you can see the
regular zero really hard to see zero for
a human okay to see zero and then we've
got the sent text image which just
happens to have really four different
colors right you got white this light
blue a dark gray and a light grey so we
can use that so anyway we close out of
this and so those are the images that
we're going to work with and then what
we're going to do is use threshold
basically to make all these images well
besides the syntax of course but I'll
just show you that threshold in will
work even in the case where you've got
like a really dark gray and I'm kind of
late each gray and then a white so what
we're going to do is threshold the
images so they're all at least these
three are exactly the same and then
there's one it's just thresholded where
it's either black or white so for that
I'm going to continue on in the next
video so anyways as always thanks for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time